ender's game by higher on Jake more and
honored Margo the title of our book is
ending and ensuring by orson scott card
the main character is andrew ender
thomas wigan he can best be described as
a creative and very strong when we
thought of character traits we agreed
that Andrew was definitely creative and
strong for example on page 20 the book
states with ender we have to strike a
delicate balance isolate him enough that
he remains creative the wise you'll
adopt the system here and we're losing
at the same time need to make sure he
keeps a strong ability to eat this code
shows that ender is creative and strong
there are also many other piece of
evidence like this scattered all
throughout the book
the daughter of the wolf is science
fiction because I had a lot of advanced
technology and is about a human aaron
ward the destination or summary we said
that ender Wiggins is the young boy who
was born to become Earth's greatest
starship commander while training tape
on this role in cases many hardships
including jealous teammates unfair
playthings and commanding his freaks and
learns to never give up in his mission
to become the bed soldier alive and so
hard work get sweaty striving for the
story mostly takes place in the Battle
School and outer space on page 33 the
book states mr. school every day hours
of classes reading numbers history
videos of bloody battles in space marine
Springs our guts all over the walls of
the bugger ships hollows other clean
Wars of her plate ships turning the
pulse of light as a spacecraft build
each other deftly your deep night many
things to learn this code describes as
setting aboard the battleship
the mood in this book is very serious
because the students of the Battle
School are often fighting for promotions
the mood in the Battle School is also
focused and better because the students
are focused on improving their skills
and some students were also bitter and
jealous Avenger skills and talents on
page 99 the code is but with this old
friends there was no laughter no
remembering just work just intelligence
and excitement about the game we're
nothing beyond that this quote describes
how the social life and spaces it is
very limited and virtually doesn't exist
and so it is a very seriously for
recommendations I would recommend
insignia by SJ Kincaid I would recommend
this book because it's also about a
young genius who has or who recruited
into the military as a combat specialist
I cuz in this book she's uh it's a 14
year old who controls the drone also my
personal recommendation is war of worlds
or HJ wells because this book is also
mostly science fiction and also is loose
Aaron's just like entertaining
for outside study I would recommend
learning a little bit of a spacecraft
outer space the child of mentality for a
young genius and how army standards work
because this book takes place in outer
space and the army and child psychology
play a big part in this book for analogy
we came up with curl and graph is to
ender as the evil witch in Hansel and
Gretel is canceled for analogy we take
this analogy because the relationships
are comparable in both relationships
there's uh there's somebody that the
main character trust but then the that
person manipulates the protagonist into
trusting them even more until they
reveal an ulterior motive that may seem
main character lose
in Ender's Game a graphic a few tries to
convince vendor that he's a friend while
really he's trying to make Enders offers
that he can be a better soldier to help
by human race and in Hansel and Gretel's
of that mother give the kid do stuff for
really he's tiny people we found some
figurative language on page 129 it is
they worked all day with the taste of
victory in their mouths and cheered
again when they broke half an hour early
for lunch the thesis books is that no
matter what challenges come forth in
your life you should never give up this
is a theme because at the beginning many
people doubt that ender deserves to be a
commander but as the both draws to a
close everyone realizes how great of a
leader he is actually improves himself
even though people put him down our
quote for this is on page 99 and there
was still the leading folder in the
standings and no one doubted that he did
outed that he deserved it now at the age
of 19 with the team leader in Phoenix
army with Petra Arkanian is his
commander this quote shows how he never
gave up because at the beginning he was
just a launching but then he kept going
without quitting even though ah people
like his original commander tried to
make him feel like he was nothing
because going and he became commander of
Dragon army and then eventually the
international food
our favorite quote was on page 194 when
Mazer Rackham's talking to ender about a
humanity he states that humanity does
not ask us to be happy it merely asked
us to be brilliant on its behalf
survival first and happiness as we can
manage it when you picked this quote
because we liked how it provided a new
and unique insight to humanity and how
life works
you